i hope that boris will look at the
cartoon and go
i don't like that and that's a little
bit embarrassing
in the topsy-turvy world of british
politics the lines between satire and
reality are blurred christian adams
political cartoonist for london's
evening standard has made a career from
mocking politicians partygate makes it
all too easy he's probably the only
politician
apart from trump probably who you can
draw from behind and everybody knows who
he is
i think a political cartoon is
it seems serious at the same time as
being uh
sort of trivial and funny so i think
it's good to have both of those things
rather than be too earnest but hopefully
it shows up
serious points i hope so
the long-awaited report by senior civil
servant sue gray talked of a serious
failure of leadership and behavior
difficult to justify criticism that
lands at the prime minister's door even
though johnson isn't explicitly named
and we know there's more to come
police are investigating 12 out of 16
gatherings far more than first thought
500 pages of evidence and 300 photos are
being poured over
despite all the damaging new claims and
clamors from some of his mps to resign
he remains in office telling a meeting
of conservative party members on monday
night that he will clean up downing
street and reshuffle his government
boris johnson presided over the biggest
election win for any political party
since 1979. a lot of his mps owe their
careers to him but is brand boris now
tarnished beyond repair
in a recent snap poll two-thirds of
voters said they wanted boris johnson to
resign following the su-grey report
83 believe he broke lockdown rules 75
believe he's not telling the truth the
conservative party is not even
pretending uh to invest in the national
interest they are considering only uh
what is in their immediate electoral
fortune if they think that the prime
minister is an electoral liability
they'll dispatch him if they think that
they can muddle through to the next
election with him on board and the
dispatching will be too costly
electorally they'll keep him that's it
and that really is an indictment of
britain's political landscape
with johnson in ukraine the focus is
back on the business of government
cabinet ministers are keen to move on
the balloons
the hat obviously
cheese in his pocket that his neck and
the wine in the minnie's suitcase but
johnson's troubles haven't gone away
and for the satirists they're a gift
that keeps on giving
neve barker al jazeera westminster